so how's the presidency going mr biden
congress is playing baseball the
president is getting booed welcome back
to hour two of our program john bachman
here with you it's one o'clock here on
the east coast 10 am out west the biden
presidency the democrat agenda on the
brink of collapse at this hour moderate
democrats kirsten cinema and joe manchin
they are holding the line on what we
call the big f in deal they are still
promising to vote no on president
biden's three and a half trillion dollar
spending package this is the house is
set to vote on a one trillion dollar
bipartisan infrastructure deal but that
has stalled out
a bill senator bernie sanders wants his
progressives to sit out
the bipartisan infrastructure bill will
not succeed
and that's what i think is the right
thing and i support the progressives
in the house for doing that
don't get everything we want we're going
to take our ball and go home that's
basically what bernie sanders is saying
now nancy pelosi says things are moving
ahead but are they really well maybe
when it comes to keeping the government
open for another couple months but
that's still kind of in jeopardy the
senate is debating a short-term funding
bill right now but the president's plans
to completely overhaul the government
obviously still in jeopardy and let's
welcome in now host of the reuben report
dave rubin author of the new book don't
burn this country
and uh dave you don't have to burn it
down it might just burn down by itself
with the way things are going at least
nobody was saying the f word
at the congressional baseball game last
night i guess
well we only had a small amount of video
there so i suspect some f-bombs might
have been thrown thrown joe biden's way
look as far as the government shutdown
at this point if you are an american in
2021 after two years of covet and
lockdowns and mandates and now putting
health care workers out of jobs if they
don't want to get vaccinated and
everything else if your conclusion is
that the government should have more
money that the government should have
more big programs that the government
should have more power over your life
well then i would like to sell you a
bridge to nowhere this is completely
ridiculous if the government shuts down
that's fine with me i i don't think they
need to come back what what are these
people doing for us other than taking
our money putting out these ridiculous
programs and yeah if bernie's not happy
let bernie walk we should be giving more
money to people we should be not giving
more money people we should be allowing
people to keep their money in the first
place and the idea that they're just
going to keep coming and taking it's
like thank god for cinema and imagine it
doesn't even matter what's in the
package right it does the idea that we
have the money in the first place we
don't have it which is why they keep
telling us is zero while they're all
flashing though their white powers right
when we do it it's white power when they
do it at zero right ryden did it
yesterday and pelosi did it and
everything else but they keep they're
literally telling us that
a bill of 3.5 trillion is zero and it's
like
yeah you know if you kept telling people
that two plus two equals five then
suddenly 3.5 does equal zero i suppose
that is the new actually um that's the
new critical race theory math i'm being
told yeah two plus two equals five
exactly
but what they're saying because what
they're saying is that 3.5 trillion if
you just tax rich people in corporations
enough it won't add to the deficit but
that doesn't make it zero you're still
stealing and taking money from those who
produce to pay for your pet projects and
again i just can't imagine being in the
shoes of somebody who would be sitting
here in america today saying yes we just
have to give them more money thus they
can fix things it's all theater that man
watching uh wearing a mask right there
it's theater is that even the real oval
office we always have to ask these
questions now based on what we saw we'll
talk about that in a second though but
you talked about the power structure
here and you know this desire to always
have one more way to kind of stick it to
you you know if you read the fine print
of the bill a lot of folks have done
this thankfully on page 168 there is a
plan to
charge or find businesses seven hundred
thousand dollars if they have employees
who don't follow through with a vaccine
mandate we don't even know if these
vaccine mandates from the federal
government are illegal yet and they're
folding this stuff into this three and a
half trillion dollar
bill i mean
it's ridiculous
john america is under assault from our
elites and democratic politicians it's
that simple and maybe republicans are
involved in it too at this point but i
would say it's mostly generated
by the far left the elite the the media
it's fueled by big tech what right would
i have i own a production company i
employ uh several full-time or several
part-timers what right would i have
as an employer of these people to say to
them you must be injected by something
otherwise i'm going to fire you i don't
own these people i thought we were
against slavery i believe that they can
make the correct medical decisions for
themselves hopefully in conjunction with
their doctors and their family and take
into consideration their own health and
whatever else is going on with them but
the idea that they're pushing this in a
3.5 trillion dollar spending deal it's
like no
let people go back to work unleash the
economy but that's not what they want
they want us all to be dependent on the
state i mean it's really true it sounds
alarmist and crazy at some level but you
know it was first democratic socialism
then they kind of admitted their
socialist and we're really ramping it up
to like full communism right now that's
what it seems like pedal to the metal
and you know the other thing too and i i
tell folks don't get bogged down in
trillion dollars here three and a half
trillion dollars there debt limit what
we've learned this week is that the only
thing unifying democrats was the money
in this bill that was promised as
handouts as favors as bribes if you will
that was what that's the democratic
party for you they have no clear
objective other than power perhaps the
money the special projects that was the
unity dave that's all that's the only
thing that holds these folks together
john that's that's a great point and
that's something that i think people on
our side let's say have to really drive
home these people have no ideas that are
congruent with human flourishing with
the idea that you are put on this earth
and you can figure out what to do and
you can hopefully build a business and
find someone you love and create a
family and own property and hand it down
to your children and build something
that will be sustainable and
generational
and truly what the human experience is
all about all they've got is give us
more money give us more power and we'll
lock you in the basement and put a mask
on you and tell you what you can eat and
by the way soon it'll be bugs
bugs i hear bugs are are big in some
parts of the world the new protein
sriracha they're not terrible but you
know
i had some bugs in mexico one time we
won't talk about that right now but i
want to talk about the nba you know
because it was interesting everyone kind
of you know who's in tune knows why the
nba did not put a mandatory uh vaccine
mandate in like other leagues have um
because of you know what we know dave
the the evidence bears us out the black
community they're not on board with
these vaccine mandates either even
though the media has tried to portray
white americans trump supporters as the
ones holding things up but jonathan
isaac is a hero to a lot of folks
because he just really put it out there
spoke about vaccines why he's not
getting one why other folks should if
they feel comfortable with it i want to
focus on this because this is how this
conversation should go and should have
been going here he is
i understand that the vaccine would um
help if if you catch cobit and uh you'll
be able to have less symptoms um from
contracting it but with me having covert
in the past and having antibodies
with my current um age group and a
fitness physical fitness level
it's not necessarily a fear of mine but
at the end of the day
i don't feel that it is um you know
anyone's reason to come out and say well
this is why or this is not why it should
just be their decision and um
you know loving your neighbors not just
loving those that agree with you or look
like you are
moving the same way that you do it it's
a you know loving those who don't
yeah jonathan isaac said it better i
think a lot of us have been trying to
say the same thing if you want to get
vaccinated get vaccinated the evidence
shows there are benefits to getting
vaccinated but if you don't want to get
vaccinated
and you're like this guy physically fit
in the right age group doesn't have
pre-existing conditions had has has
covid already or had it before and has
the antibodies
you know he should be the spokesperson
for covet he's a lot more effective
communicator than a lot of these public
health officials
well john it's not only everything he
said there that you just repeated but
it's that listen to the tone listen to
the tone he's not trying to control
people he's saying i'm allowed to ask
questions this is what i've been through
i i am of this age and this health you
should do what's best for you it's the
most calm rational way of discussing any
of this you know we played this clip
yesterday on my show and i juxtaposed it
with kareem abdul-jabbar who of course
was a basketball player you know 34
years ago and he basically was saying
that every nba player must uh get
vaccinated and in essence he was saying
otherwise they're evil that that's
basically that's that's their argument
by the way
by the way john kareem abdul-jabbar
during the riots the race riots that we
were having all last summer uh he was
all for people being out there and
rioting because you know that was for
social justice so in that case you can
be outside coughing all over each other
you know sweating all over each other
patting each other in the back but when
you have the elite athletes of the world
the people who are truly in the best
condition who are the youngest who as
isaac said
has already had kovit has immunities now
he's a bad guy yeah and this is just
such a perfect example of why our
dialogue in this country is so screwed
up what happened to personal choice what
happened to individual rights your own
capacity to make decisions for yourself
that's the stuff i want to get back to
but we are fighting something that is
just as you said before it's escalating
it's getting worse and maybe here's a
little silver lining i've not been a
little dark this morning maybe the
silver lining is it's it's escalating
and getting crazier because it's running
out of room it's running out of air it's
so hysterical maybe maybe the darkest
point is right before the dawn uh and i
will say this about kareem abdul-jabbar
he has never been the same ever since he
left basketball to become a pilot
you know
you you get that joke i don't know how
many people but that he had the fish he
had the fish if i'm not mistaken yes uh
real quickly too another thing i wanted
to ask you about why is joe biden so
hairy and why do we have to see this
dave um
i you know i i saw him do you have some
pictures for us no we're not gonna oh
we're out okay we're not gonna show the
pictures we're trying to work around
this you know a lot of folks were
watching this they were tweeting me on
the air no get the close-up shot we want
to make sure he's getting the vaccine we
don't and i was like you don't want to
see the close-up shot nobody needs to
see
the close-up shot
listen if you want to see the close-up
shot i would just recommend watching
1985 teen wolf with michael j fox and
the first time he turns into the wolf
that's that's joe biden's arm is that a
side effect of the kovid vaccine i don't
know but i think we just handed media
matters their clip of newsmax and dave
rubin and john bachmann today as they
will put this out and say we're
spreading this information that the
vaccine can turn you into a werewolf
headline newsmax anchor says covid
vaccine causes werewolf syndrome
which we didn't actually say it's just a
joke of course teen wolf great movie too
by the way great great flick
dave indeed great to see as always
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell